Transcriber:
We live in a culture
that doesn't take mental health
issues seriously.
There's a lot of stigma.
Some people tell you to just suck it up,
or get it together, or to stop worrying,
or that it's all in your head.
But I'm here to tell you
that anxiety disorders,
they're as real as diabetes.
(Music)
[Body Stuff with Dr. Jen Gunter]
Hi again.
It's Dr. Jen,
and I've noticed something
with my patients.
They often describe to me
some classic symptoms
of an anxiety disorder.
Constant worry, trouble sleeping,
tense muscles and struggle
with concentrating.
But they aren't getting treatment.
There's a lot of issues
with mental-health care in this country.
Some people don't have
insurance that would cover it.
Some have been dismissed
or minimized in the past,
and don't think seeking
help will do any good.
Some worry about the stigma
and whether it could affect
future jobs or relationships.
But severe anxiety
isn't a moral or personal failing.
It's a health problem,
just like strep throat or diabetes.
It needs to be treated
with the same kind of seriousness.
Before we can talk
about anxiety disorders,
let's talk about anxiety itself.
Anxiety is the very real
and normal emotion
we feel in a stressful situation.
It's related to fear.
But while fear is a response
to an immediate threat
that quickly subsides,
anxiety is a response
to more uncertain threats
that tends to last much longer.
It's all part of the threat
detection system,
which all animals have to some degree,
to help protect us from predators.
Anxiety starts in the brain's amygdala,
a pair of almond-sized nerve bundles
that alert other areas of the brain
to be ready for defensive action.
Next, the hypothalamus relays the signal,
setting off what we call
the stress response in our body.
Our muscles tense,
our breathing and heart rate increase
and our blood pressure rises.
Areas in the brain stem kick in
and put you in a state of high alertness.
This is the fight-or-flight response.
There are ways
the fight-or-flight response
is kept somewhat in check,
with an area of higher-level thinking
called the ventromedial prefrontal cortex.
It works like this.
If a person sees something
they think is dangerous, like a tiger,
that sends a signal to the amygdala,
saying "it's time to run."
The ventromedial prefrontal cortex
can say to the amygdala,
"Hey, look. The tiger's in a cage.
You know what a cage is?
They can't escape from a cage.
It's OK to calm down."
It's a feedback loop
that can help keep the response in check.
The hippocampus is also involved.
It provides context, saying things like,
"Hey, we've seen tigers in cages before.
We're in a zoo. You are extra safe."
With anxiety,
these threat-detection systems
and mechanisms that reduce or inhibit them
are functioning incorrectly
and cause us to worry about the future
and our safety in it.
But for many people,
it goes into overdrive.
They experience persistent
pervasive anxiety
that disrupts work,
school and relationships
and leads them to avoid situations
that may trigger symptoms.
Anxiety disorders are not at all uncommon.
Based on data from
the World Mental Health Survey,
researchers estimate
that about 16 percent of individuals
currently have or have had
an anxiety disorder.
These include social anxiety disorder,
panic disorder, agoraphobia and phobias.
Studies have shown
that people with anxiety disorders
don't just have a different way
of reacting to stress.
There may be actual differences
in how their brain is working.
One model describes possible mix-ups
in the connections between the amygdala
and other parts of the brain.
The pathways that signal anxiety
become stronger.
And the more anxiety you have,
the stronger the pathways become,
and it becomes a vicious cycle.
The good news is
there's treatment for anxiety,
and that you don't have to suffer.
Remember, this isn't about weakness.
It's about changing brain patterns,
and research shows that our brains
have the ability to reorganize
and form new connections
all throughout our lives.
A good first step is to do the basics.
Eat a balanced diet,
exercise regularly
and get plenty of sleep,
as your mind is part of your body.
It might also help to try meditation.
Instead of our heart rate rising
and our body tensing,
with mindfulness and breathing,
we can slow down
the fight-or-flight response
and improve how we feel in the moment.
Cognitive behavioral therapy,
a form of talk therapy,
can also be fantastic.
In it, you learn to identify
upsetting thoughts
and determine whether they're realistic.
Over time, cognitive behavioral therapy
can rebuild those neural pathways
that tamp down the anxiety response.
Medication can also give relief,
in both the short-term and the long-term.
In the short-term, anti-anxiety drugs
can down-regulate
the threat-detection mechanisms
that are going into overdrive.
Studies have shown
that both long-term medications
and cognitive behavioral therapy
can reduce that overreactivity
of the amygdala
we see an anxiety disorders.
High blood pressure and diabetes,
they can be treated or managed over time.
And the same is true
for an anxiety disorder too.